und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend eine zusammenkunft zum runden
geburtstag eines hirntoten will man sich
wenn überhaupt dann gewiss nicht
fröhlich vorstellen schon eine einladung
dazu muss geschmacklos wirken und
trotzdem zeigt frankreichs präsident
makro selbst heute da queen elizabeth
aus anlass des 70 geburtstags der nato
in den buckingham palace let keine reue
für seine wortwahl hirntod für die nato
die brutale diagnose habe ihren zweck
erfüllt aufmerksamkeit darauf gelenkt
dass die nato in der tat mehr hirn
bräuchte als sie gerade zeige damit hat
er mag jedenfalls dafür gesorgt dass
heute keiner bloß in superlativen
schwelgen kann von einem bündnis das
eine milliarde menschen über den
atlantik vereint und das erfolgreichste
der geschichte sei es muss heute schon
auch um jetzt und um morgen gehen in
london
yasin herrlein es dort
die nato kann von glück sagen dass die
gastgeberin des gipfels empfangs die
queen ist denn die hat einen schatz ein
diplomatische erfahrung der
seinesgleichen sucht was das bündnis gut
gebrauchen kann am abend eines tages an
dem von einigkeit wenig zu spüren war
den ton setzte emmanuel markt kaum
bereits zuvor mit seiner provokativen
aussage die nato sei strategisch hirntod
was den amerikanischen präsidenten auf
den plan rief der seinerseits vor einer
weile das transatlantische bündnis für
überflüssig erklärt hatte das ist ein
ganz herzlicher kommentar gegenüber den
anderen 28 mitgliedsstaaten man kann so
etwas nicht sagen das ist sehr
respektlos
der nato-generalsekretär freut sich und
pflichtet bei das stimmt nicht die nato
ist aktiv sie ist agil und passt sich an
gelegenheit die differenzen auszuräumen
hatten trump und marken dann theoretisch
bei einem bilateralen treffen
dies fand in der residenz des
amerikanischen botschafters in london
statt wer spricht dabei wm vor wem
gelingt es breitbeinig auf dem stuhl zu
sitzen im ton mag ja übers ziel
hinausgeschossen sein inhaltlich bleibt
makro bei seiner kritik
wir können unmöglich sagen wir geben
geld und soldaten ohne klarheit darüber
was die nato sein sollte das bleibt
unklar
als wenn das bündnis nicht schon genug
sorgen hätte neben dem ewigen streit ums
liebe geld ist da vor allem noch die
militärische intervention der türkei in
nordsyrien präsident erdogan ist der
mann mit sprengkraft potenzial für den
gipfel
wie war das noch so schön einfach vor 70
jahren als das bündnis gegründet wurde
da gab es einen klaren feind die
sowjetunion existiert nicht mehr aber
der umgang mit dem heutigen russland
gestaltet sich inzwischen ja auch nicht
gerade einfach präsident putin sendete
unterdes liebesgrüße aus sotschi mit dem
angebot mit der nato zu kooperieren
nach dem empfang im buckingham palast
kamen die staatschefs dann noch zum
abendessen in der downing street
zusammen es wurde jetzt auch gelächelt
vielleicht hatte das treffen mit der
queen ja tatsächlich seine wirkung
erzielt bei allen differenzen die es
gibt und die wir natürlich auch
aussprechen müssen wir müssen auch über
die zukunft der nato und die
strategischen gemeinsamkeiten
diskutieren aber ich gehe relativ
optimistisch in dieses treffen mit
spannung ist die morgige abschluss
erklärung zu erwarten in der angeblich
unter anderem china als mögliche neue
bedrohung genannt werden soll
vielleicht gelingt es ja wenigstens hier
über einigung zu erzielen für frieden
und sicherheit
[Musik]
das ist sehr hübsch aber wir müssen doch
zur hatten sache zurück diana nicht mehr
hirntod das heißt das noch lange nicht
dass die nato gesund ist wie viel leben
steckt noch in ihr nach ihrer
beobachtung dieses gipfels der gipfel
hat jedoch kaum angefangen
er findet ja tatsächlich erst morgen
statt und tatsächlich kommt das ganze
unter merkwürdigen auspizien zusammen
eine geburtstagsfeier bei der zwei der
wichtigen gäste das geburtstagskind als
hirntot oder obsolet bezeichnet haben
allerdings die nato will sich jetzt hier
einmal bestätigen bei dieser
geburtstagsfeier und klarmachen dass sie
eben das wichtigste und größte
militärbündnis ist dass sie die großen
strategischen fragen der zukunft angeht
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg soll
eine art arbeitsauftrag bekommen diese
fragen in zukunft heraus zu arbeiten und
bei gesundheit geht es natürlich auch
ein bisschen ums geld und da ist es so
dass in der amtszeit von donald trump
die ausgaben für die nato um 130
milliarden dollar gestiegen sein werden
so viel mehr haben die staaten dann in
das bündnis hinein gezahlt und das hat
donald trump so zufrieden gemacht dass
er die nato dass er heute gesagt hat er
sei ein fan der nato ja in der tat ist
ja der größte störfaktor heute nicht der
französische und nicht der amerikanische
präsident sondern der türkische
präsident erdogan fordert
bedingungslosen rückhalt der nato für
sein vorgehen in nordsyrien und
unterstützt diese bitte mit massiven
drohungen wie soll das ausgehen
ja das ist sozusagen der knackpunkt des
morgigen tages es soll ein gemeinsamer
abschluss bereich bericht unterzeichnet
werden und momentan droht erdogan damit
das nicht zu tun
solange die nato nicht gewillt ist die y
pg als terror-gruppe einzustufen das ist
insofern eben problematisch als die y pb
die kurden in syrien gemeinsam mit den
amerikanern gegen den as gekämpft haben
und nun müsste sich die nato von dieser
gruppe so stark distanzieren dass sie
tatsächlich auch als terroristen
bezeichnet sowie die kurden sie in
nordsyrien momentan bekämpfen zu
erwarten ist dass man da einen eleganten
kompromiss findet hoffentlich denn
erdogan droht eben momentan damit diesen
abschlussbericht zu boykottieren wird
man den morgen ein bisschen mehr von
boris johnson sehen das ist ganz so
auffällig dass er den gipfel in seiner
stadt eben kaum mit seiner gegenwart
zierte jedenfalls nicht vor kameras
tatsächlich ist es so dass boris johnson
nicht so gerne mit donald trump gesehen
werden möchte donald trump ist bei den
briten extrem unbeliebt und boris
johnson glaubt dass der sehr schöne
vorsprung den er momentan in den
umfragen hat vor den parlamentswahlen
hier nächsten donnerstag schrumpfen
könnte wenn er sich zu sehr in der nähe
des amerikanischen präsidenten auf
hitler ist ja außerdem ausgesprochen
unberechenbar
er wurde wohl gut gebrieft er wurde
nämlich heute gefragt welche position er
zu den wahlen einem monat gesagt er habe
schon vielen leuten dazu verholfen
wahlen zu gewinnen aber zu den
britischen wollte er jetzt nichts sagen
ich nehme an dass paris johnson in
morgen nicht ganz vermeiden kann aber er
wird auf distanz bleiben
dankeschön diana und sie finden
geschichte hintergrund und analysen zur
nato auf heute.de damit zur berliner
politik seit samstag weiß man ja mit
welcher spitze die spd in ihre nächste
phase geht eine neue phase man weiß aber
nicht wohin
das weist die spd selbst nicht das weiß
wohl noch nicht mal die neue spitze die
heute tagt und berät
orientierungslosigkeit lässt sich
schlecht verkaufen deshalb ist jetzt
wieder viel von sachthemen die rede
um die es im kern gehen soll und
einem sachthema kann man sich so gut
festhalten wie an der berühmten
schwarzen null null neuverschuldung um
den staatshaushalt zu finanzieren
olaf scholz steht für diese schwarze
null
die frage ist ob die jetzt mit ihm
fallen soll
ob die deutsche republik nach all den
fetten jahren den weg in den zukunft nur
auf pump finanzieren kann
florian hahn über diese sachfragen wenn
die regierung mehr geld will müssen sie
es hier beschaffen
heute mittag ein kurzer blick in einen
der unscheinbarsten aber vielleicht
wichtigsten handels seele frankfurt hier
macht die finanzagentur des bundes mit
deutschlands schulden gerade
ein unfassbar gutes geschäft nein sie im
auftrag des staates etwa 100 euro
seit der dafür keinen zinsen im
gegenteil zwei euro 80 gibt's obendrauf
quasi als gebühr geschenkt weil
deutschland so vertrauenswürdig ist und
viele investoren nicht wissen wohin
sonst mit dem geld ein gutes argument
gerade jetzt mehr schulden zu machen
meinen auch konservative ökonomen
wir haben nachholbedarf im bereich der
kommunen im bereich der infrastruktur
und wir haben neue themen
digitalisierung dekarbonisierung also
klimapolitik all das muss finanziert
werden investieren auf pump unter
anderem mit dieser forderung hatten sie
die spd uhr wahl gewonnen
norbert walter borjans und saskia es
gibt heute kein auftritt kein wort der
beiden stattdessen sitzung im
willy-brandt-haus man bereitet den
parteitag vor und die frage welche
forderungen die spd jetzt an die union
stellt eine davon die schwarze null
aufzugeben
ich kann diese zuneigung zur abstrakten
begriffen nicht wirklich nachvollziehen
die union sollte vor allen dingen das
land lieben und dazu muss man es
modernisieren und muss investieren
es wäre die abwicklung seiner politik
olaf scholz immer noch finanzminister
wer heute ebenfalls in die spd-zentrale
gefahren
stolz der gern vom soliden haushalten
spricht und erst recht nicht an die
nächste hürde will ans grundgesetz
seit 2009 steht darin die schuldenbremse
eine regel die nur wenig schulden
erlaubt in diesem jahr wären es maximal
sechs milliarden euro
auch das vielen zu strengen selbst
christian castrop die schuldenbremse 1
im finanzministerium mit entwickelte die
bremse habe viel erreicht sagt er
heute sei sie überholt es wäre jetzt
ganz besonders wichtig dass deutschland
geld in die hand nimmt um bestimmte
investitionen zu tätigen
zum beispiel in eine höhere
produktivität für die zukunft die zinsen
sind extrem billig und wir müssen diese
zeit jetzt nutzen neue schulden ein
rotes tuch für die schwarzen die die
schwarze null wahlweise zum markenkern
erklären oder wie zuletzt selbstironisch
auf twitter zum fetisch und deren
haushälter auf ein echtes problem
verweisen
wir haben keine finanzierungsprobleme in
deutschland wieder für investitionen
noch für andere dinge sondern wir haben
umsetzungsprobleme beispiel
schulsanierungen 2017 stellte der bund
dafür 3,5 milliarden euro bereits
ausgegeben bis heute wegen komplizierter
verfahren nur ein bruchteil 80 millionen
in deutschland und die schuldenfrage das
land bekommt frisches geld gerade
geschenkt nur mit dem ausgeben klappt es
nicht ganz so gut
auch das sind sorgt nachrichten von
gundula gause
am zweiten tag ihres besuchs in
afghanistan hat verteidigungsministerin
kramp karrenbauer einen dialog der
regierung in kabul mit den radikal
islamischen taliban gefordert
friedensgespräche müssten die
afghanischen verantwortlichen mit
einbeziehen bislang verhandeln nur die
usa mit den militanten islamisten über
einen truppenabzug in masar i scharif
dankte kramp karrenbauer den deutschen
soldaten für ihren einsatz
man arbeite seit jahren seite an seite
für ein freies und friedliches
afghanistan
dies sei erfolgreich und dies wolle man
fortsetzen
die neue pisa studie bescheinigt
deutschland erneut mängel im
bildungssystem
nach angaben der studienverfasser der
oecd liegen die schüler in deutschland
über dem durchschnitt allerdings würden
ihre leistungen schwächer in allen drei
test bereichen lesen mathematik und
naturwissenschaften
bundesbildungsministerin carlitscheck
zeigte sich alarmiert darüber dass ein
fünftel aller 15 jährigen kaum in der
lage sei den sinn von texten zu erfassen
grundsätzlich zweifeln experten dagegen
immer wieder die methodik der erhebung
an einen in deutschland besonders
starken zusammenhang zwischen sozialer
herkunft und bildung bestätigt auch der
neue bericht zum stand der integration
die bundesbeauftragte widmann mauz
erklärte deutschland könne integration
die bundesrepublik sei ein
einwanderungsland zugleich forderte sie
eine bessere sprachförderung für kinder
und mehr unterstützung für zugewanderte
frauen zur integration auf dem
arbeitsmarkt
der generalbundesanwalt will gut drei
monate nach dem mord an einem
tschetschenen in berlin offenbar die
ermittlungen an sich ziehen
es gebe neue erkenntnisse dass die tat
vom russischen staat gesteuert wurde
wie mehrere medien übereinstimmend
berichten der mutmaßliche täter ein
49-jähriger mit russischem pass war kurz
nach der tat im august gefasst worden
der getötete soll im tschetschenien
krieg mit separatisten gegen russland
gekämpft haben zweifel an der
glaubwürdigkeit der regierung von malta
äußerten vertreter des europäischen
parlaments bei einem besuch in dem eu
mittels start nach dem mord an der
investigative journalistin darf ne caro
anna galizia warnte auch die eu
kommission die regierung in valletta
sich in die ermittlungen ein zu löschen
auf malta sagten
europaabgeordnete ministerpräsident
muskat stehe für den sumpf aus finanz
kriminalität und korruption der die
journalistin das leben gekostet habe die
beziehungen zwischen brüssel und malta
seien ernsthaft beeinträchtigt
das iranische staatsfernsehen hat heute
eingeräumt dass die sogenannten
sicherheitskräfte letzten monat tödliche
gewalt angewandt haben
die regierung vermeidet dabei
zahlenangaben gesteht aber immerhin das
offensichtliche jetzt ein ermittler von
amnesty international kommen über ihre
informanten auf 208 toten andere
respektierte menschenrechtsgruppen
schätzen hunderte mehr
und das würde die proteste gegen die
massive erhöhung des benzinpreises gegen
die wirtschaftliche und politische lage
des landes zu den schwersten
möglicherweise seit beginn der
islamischen republik machen
die opfer waren meist arbeits und
hoffnungslose junge leute und das
geschah hinter einer lange fast
perfekten absperrung von kommunikation
und internet und erst allmählich jetzt
mit ein paar wochen verspätung kommen
schicksale und ein gesamtbild zu stande
kamen safia realen bericht er geht gegen
das regime auf die straße und filmt
dabei die proteste pro jahr bach theorie
27 jahre alt es ist der sechzehnter
november unweit von teheran
er beschreibt selbst die lage
wenig später ist er tot erschossen von
sicherheitskräften
sein vater und sein großvater sind
fassungslos mein sohn musste unschuldig
sterben warum das ist sein großvater den
er über alles liebte er war mein ein und
alles
pro jahr ist jetzt weg und ich werde ihm
folgen ich will nicht mehr leben
was als protest gegen erhöhte
benzinpreise beginnt endet in
bürgerkriegsähnlichen szenen
bilder der letzten wochen
sicherheitskräfte schießen von dächern
und hubschraubern auf demonstranten
videos zeigen auch panzer in der stadt
macht hier sollen bis zu einem der
proteste getötet worden sein berichtet
die new york times
anderswo berichten augenzeugen wie
verletzte aus krankenhäusern verschleppt
worden sein sollen
ihm droht die todesstrafe bis heute gibt
es keine offiziellen opferzahlen
man hört von über 100 vielleicht auch
mehreren hunderten von toten von
tausenden gefangenen aber genaue zahlen
gibt es nicht die behörden irans weigern
sich diese zahlen heraus zu geben auch
dass wieder ein zeichen der
verschleierung im gegenteil es gibt
immer wieder vertreter des ayatollahs
die im fernsehen dazu aufrufen
protestler die sie gewaltverbrecher
nennen zu gefangenzunehmen zu foltern
und auch hinzurichten
tagelang war das internet geblockt das
regime wollte die willkür der
sicherheitskräfte nicht zeigen
selbst iranische journalisten im ausland
via mazana die werden massiv unter druck
gesetzt bedroht journalisten im in und
ausland wir sollen nicht über die
proteste berichten schon häufig hat man
meine familie angerufen und bedrängt wo
ist er was macht er massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen im iran
die opposition in berlin wirft der
bundesregierung sprachlosigkeit vor
die bundesregierung glaubt durch
leisetreterei ja wegen des atom
abkommens über die menschenrechte
schweigen zu müssen das ist schlicht
falsch
und deshalb ist das fahrlässig die
bundesregierung muss sehr klar und
deutlich position beziehen und klar
machen dass wir nicht auf der seite der
gewalt stehen sondern auf die auf der
seite derjenigen die einfach ihre
fundamentalen rechte von purbach theorie
ein gesicht der unruhen im iran 2009 10
das regime hat unterdessen die proteste
offiziell für beendet erklärt das ist
der schock vom august letzten jahres in
ein bild gefroren der ponte morandi eine
der wichtigsten brücken italiens
eingestürzt
43 menschen kamen damals ums leben ein
wunder dass es nicht mehr waren
italiens justiz versucht die
verantwortlichen zur verantwortung zu
ziehen
73 sind beschuldigt jetzt die neue
brücke nähert sich ihre veränderung
enthüllt die zeitung la repubblica
vorgänge in den verantwortlichen firmen
die den schlimmen verdacht verstärken
danach war dort geld wichtiger als
menschenleben
alissa jung berichtet an einem
regnerischen sommer tag im august 2008
10 änderte sich emanuel diaz leben für
immer
seit diesem tag ist nichts mehr wie es
vorher war an diesem tag stützte die
morandi brücke in genua ein
[Musik]
ich habe mich bei facebook eingeloggt
und sah wie die brücke eingestürzt ist
dann habe ich immer und immer wieder
versucht meinen bruder anzurufen was
sich bei facebook bilder gesehen habe
auf denen sein auto zu erkennen war dass
aus den trümmern gezogen wurde
in diesem moment habe ich realisiert
dass mein bruder tot ist insgesamt 43
menschen kamen ums leben
besonders schmerzhaft für die
angehörigen noch immer läuft die suche
nach den verantwortlichen ein neu
aufgetauchtes dokument zeigt nun dass
die betreiberfirma schon vorher von der
einsturzgefahr der brücke wusste wir
haben diverse anzeichen dafür es tut mir
leid das sagen zu müssen dass die
arbeiten der betreibergesellschaften
bereits vorher ein risiko angezeigt
haben
das haben ihre eigenen dokumente gezeigt
und zwar ein so großes risiko dass
sofort sehr gründlich und aufmerksam
hätte behoben werden müssen
die verantwortliche betreiber firma ist
autostrada per l'italia tochter des
unternehmens atlantia dessen wichtigste
aktionär die milliardärsfamilie benetton
ist als privatunternehmen sind sie ein
profit interessiert autostrada
versicherte direkt nach dem unglück alle
wartungsarbeiten und kontrollen seien
korrekt durchgeführt worden werden
nichts von einem einsturz risiko gewusst
recherchen der zeitung la republica
behaupten jetzt das gegenteil über das
ein sturzrisiko wussten beide bescheid
autos gerade und 2
das ist die firma die für die kontrolle
der autobahn zuständig ist und noch viel
schlimmer
la repubblica berichtet die dokumente
wurden schöngefärbt nach 2016 haben sie
die bewertung in dem dokument geändert
aus ein sturzrisiko wurde risiko eines
stabilitäts verlust
das ist eine andere sache bei einem
einsturz risiko hätte die straße sofort
gesperrt werden müssen aber das
passierte nicht
die angehörigen wollen nun dass die
verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden
die menschen die ihr leben verloren
haben verdienen gerechtigkeit und auch
italien verdient gerechtigkeit das land
hat
ruf verloren um den wiederherzustellen
bauen sie diese neue brücke sicher soll
sie sein und genoas offene wunde
schließen nachrichten von gundula gause
nochmal jetzt aus der wirtschaft die
zoll streitigkeiten der usa mit ihren
handelspartnern in asien und europa sind
weiterhin das beherrschende thema an den
finanzmärkten
jetzt drohte us-präsident trump mit
neuen zellen auf französischen
champagner und käse valerie haller und
das ist eine reaktion auf die digital
steuer in frankreich richtig und da
bahnt sich jetzt vielleicht der nächste
handelsstreit an der weit über
frankreich hinaus gehen könnte
amerikanische internet unternehmen wie
apple google amazon und facebook machen
jahr milliardenumsätze zahlen dafür aber
kaum steuern
das wollte sich die regierung in paris
nicht mehr bieten lassen und erhebt seit
dem sommer eine digital steuer im
alleingang eine einheitliche eu-regelung
war nämlich zuvor gescheitert auch wegen
mangelnder unterstützung aus deutschland
die usa finden die steuer unfair und
drohen frankreich nun mit hohem
vergeltungs zellen bis zu 100 prozent
auf waren aus frankreich das würde
französische exporte treffen im wert von
gut zwei milliarden dollar in den
französischen medien herrscht deswegen
helle aufregung empfindlich teurer
würden ausgerechnet symbolträchtige
waren wein käse kosmetik und handtaschen
ob die zelle tatsächlich in kraft treten
soll im januar entschieden werden bisher
also nur eine drohung
aber die wirkt schon aktien von pariser
luxus firmen wie hermès l'oreal und lvmh
reagieren mit deutlichen kursverlusten
ähnliches droht auch australien italien
großbritannien und österreich denn auch
sie wollen eine digital steuer einführen
oder haben dies schon getan retten
könnte es eine globale mindeststeuer für
internet gedanken bis da aber ein plan
auf dem tisch liegt der alle zufrieden
stellt kann es noch dauern
ja das bleibt eine herausforderung
vielen dank valerie eine meldung vom
sport die deutschen handballerinnen
haben bei der wm in japan vorzeitig den
einzug
hauptrunde geschafft mit dem dritten
sieg im dritten spiel der gruppenphase
gegen rekord olympiasieger dänemark
gingen sie schon früh in führung
zwar konnten die gegnerinnen zehn
minuten vor schluss ausgleichen aber die
deutschen behielten die nerven und
setzten sich am ende mit 26 25 durch
spatenstich in berlin heute für das
museum der moderne
damit beginnt die auf sieben jahre
angelegte bauphase für das
prestigeträchtige projekt zwischen
philharmonie und neuer nationalgalerie
das museum für die kunst des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts soll rund 450 millionen
euro kosten ein großteil aus
bundesmitteln
der entwurf der schweizer
stararchitekten herzog & de meuron ist
allerdings umstritten und wird von den
einen als bierzelt oder kunstscheune von
anderen als visionär bezeichnet
heute vor 30 jahren war es schon fast
einen monat her dass die mauer in berlin
aufging und menschen sich frei zwischen
deutschland ost und deutschland west
bewegen konnten
aber es ging nicht überall nahe der
deutsch deutschen grenze wo sich der
brocken im harz über 1100 meter aus der
ebene erhebt war ein bereich noch
abgeschottet wie die meiste zeit des
kalten krieges der horchposten von
volksarmee und rote armee
der berg eine festung und darf an die
bürger der ddr das ist höchste zeit war
auch dieses relikt zu knacken
friedlich und fröhlich und es gelang so
waren die zeiten damals daran haben die
menschen der region heute erinnert und
annegret oster war dabei eine reise in
die vergangenheit die noch gar nicht so
lange zurück liegt
langsam schraubt sich der sonderzug der
harzer schmalspurbahn hoch auf den
brocken in den waggons erzählen
zeitzeugen von dem tag vor genau 30
jahren hat sich dort auf dem gipfel die
mauer öffnete dann wurde verhandelt
nur mit dem diensthabenden offizier das
tor ging auf und dann strömten die menge
wir sind doch umgesprungen wie träumen
kommen heute machte folgen teilten wenn
ich daran denke wie schön dass für die
berufsschüler aus quedlinburg erzählt
der 70-jährige von einer anderen welt
das ist auf jeden fall unvorstellbar was
sie früher so abbing was man sich
heutzutage echt nicht vorstellen können
ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen
mir sagen lassen die da darf ich
hinfahren das darf ich jetzt nicht
machen
heutzutage bin ich heute bock habe da
hoch zu wandern oder mache ich das zu
ddr zeiten war das unmöglich
der höchste berg norddeutschlands war
militärische sperrzone das broken
plateau strategisch wichtige horchposten
der roten armee umschlossen von
anderthalb kilometern betonmauer
bis zum 3
12 1989 freie bürger freier brocken eine
bürgerbewegung hatte zum protestmarsch
auf dem berg aufgerufen
tausende menschen folgten der fotograf
hans jörg hörselgau war dabei der druck
nahm langsam zu
und dann ist auf der wetterstation ein
transparent enthüllt worden mauer weg da
haben die menschen gejubelt
der diensthabende major der konnte
diesem druck eigentlich gar nicht mehr
widerstehen also da musste diese mauer
öffnen oder das tor öffnen
die menschen strömten auf den gipfel
standen auf einmal an dem ort der 28
jahre lang zwar sichtbar aber
unerreichbar war
für menschen aus ost und west die
teerung erinnert sich noch gut
es war herrliches wetter es war totale
sicht und es war ein unbeschreibliches
gefühl
emotionen pur und da muss sich
vorstellen hier war militärische
sperrgebiet und hier war die letzte
bastion und die die wollten wir fallen
der brocken die letzte bastion die
friedlich zurückerobert wurde von den
menschen im harz knapp einen monat nach
dem mauerfall ja 30 jahre mauer war
jetzt haben wir wirklich viel dazu
gemacht wie jedes mal wenn so ein
vorschlag in die redaktion kommt kommt
dann aber so und so viele
und dann kommt wieder so eine geschichte
und macht sie das
989 00 30 gibt's wieder nachrichten und
heute plus mit einer zimmermann
bis morgen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter hoher luftdruck
bestimmt morgen das wetter in
deutschland
dieses hoch hier das zieht allmählich
richtung südosten europas und sorgt für
viel sonnenschein im tagesverlauf
zunächst einmal bildet sich in der nacht
nebel und zwar von der ems bis zum main
und da kann auch reifglätte dabei seien
die temperaturen gehen ordentlich zurück
im nordosten da sind viele wolken
unterwegs vor allem an der ostsee da
kann es auch mal regnen im süden klart
es auf und dort gehen die temperaturen
besonders weit zurück bis auf minus acht
grad 7 grad am mildesten in
schleswig-holstein morgen im
tagesverlauf gibt es zunächst einmal
etwas nebel und dann lockert es auf die
sonne scheint vor allem im süden längere
zeit nach norden sind zwar auch einige
wolken unterwegs aber auch dort zeigt
sich mal die sonne
temperaturmäßig liegen wir mit 1 bis 8
grad in deutschland vor allem im norden
dann im mittleren bereich im süden ist
es etwas kälter
am donnerstag wird es sonnig sein und
bei temperaturen bei ein bis sieben grad
die temperaturen steigen etwas zum
freitag bis 10 grad an der nordsee wird
es stürmisch werden und es kommt neuer
regen vor allem dann von nordwesten rein
und samstag da lässt der wind etwas an
der nordsee nach aber insgesamt bleibt
es ziemlich wechselhaft damit wünsche
ich ihnen ein schöner abend